[Musique]
et problème de la vie chère les
problèmes du chômage et pour bien des
enfants de leur éducation de leur avenir
je souhaite vous en parler j'ai déjà
commencé un peu ce matin la radio et je
continuerai au cours de la campagne mais
ce soir pour la première grande émission
télévisée de cette campagne officielle
je vais vous parler quelque chose qui
est sans doute plus difficile mais qui
me paraît dominé le reste parce que je
crois qu'il faut bien s'en rendre compte
nous sommes confrontés
un défi qui nous est imposée par une
puissance étrangère qui est l'union
soviétique
ce défi est fantastique c'est le défi du
communisme
ils mettent en cause notre liberté en
tant qu'être humain et en tant que
français serons-nous le relevé de la
réponse à cette question et pendant
toutes les autres selon que nous serons
libres ou pas nous pourrons décider de
notre avenir nous pourrons décider des
moyens des politiques que nous voulons
adopter ou nous ne le pourront pas je
pense par conséquent que c'est le débat
qui devrait dominer cette campagne
officielle et je crois qu'il faut qu'il
soit posée je trouve d'ailleurs que
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing et
bien cavaliers lorsqu il écarte d'un
revers de main les critiques qui peuvent
lui être faites à ce sujet en disant
comment osez-vous entre éthique en ma
politique étrangère vous abaissez la
france et voyons comment peut-il cincy
s'identifier à la france comme on ne
comprend t-il pas que si je critique sa
politique étrangère ça n'est pas pour
abaisser la france au contraire c'est
parce que je pense que la politique
qu'il mène conduit à un abaissement de
notre pays
aux jo ni ne dit pas du tout qu'il ait
voulu n'est-il les souhaité ni même
qu'il ait consenti je pense qu'il est
plein de bonnes intentions mais je pense
qu'il s'est trompé et je pense qu'il
s'est trompé par orgueil il s'est cru
plus intelligent que les autres et en
particulier plus intelligent que les
autres chefs d'état il s'essaie des
illusions il s'est fait des illusions
sur la détente
il s'est fait des illusions sur l'europe
il s'est fait des illusions sur le tiers
monde il a cru que la diplomatie était
une affaire de relations personnelles
alors que c'est une affaire de relation
de force
il a cru que s'il était lui bien avec
monsieur brejnev la france aurait une
bonne politique pour la paix c'est faux
il accueille que s'il était lui bien
avec monsieur helmut schmidt
la france serait une bonne politique
européenne c'est faux en tout cas c'est
insuffisant
il a cru que s'il avait lui de bonnes
relations avec tel ou tel chef d'état
africain la france aurait une bonne
politique africaine
c'est faux en tout cas c'est insuffisant
monsieur giscard d'estaing n'a pas
compris que les états sont des monstres
froids comme disait de gaulle et il me
fait parfois l'effet d'une libellule qui
voudrait séduire des monstres froids
alors il les suit deux échecs et il en
est où marie mais il ne faudrait pas que
la france puisse en est atteinte
justement
alors essayons de voir un peu ce qu'il
en est ensemble tout est parti du rêve
européen giscardien lorsqu'il est arrivé
au pouvoir en 1974 le président de la
république actuel est un intellectuel
mathématicien à penser que la france
était un pays trop moyen pour avoir un
grand avenir et que cet avenir se
trouverait seulement dans un ensemble
plus vaste qui devait être l'heure il a
pensé qu'il serait l'homme qui assure
cette mutation historique entre la
france française et la france européenne
il a fallu cinq ans pour s'apercevoir de
ce que chacun peut constater en un
instant c'est que les nations
européennes sont liés par l'histoire par
des intérêts économiques par la
proximité géographique mais que dans
l'état actuel
l'europe se caractérise par le fait
qu'un des principaux pays qui la
constituent l'allemagne est coupée en
deux entre l'est et l'ouest et que du
fait de cette situation il n'y a pas de
défense européenne possible autonome
pour l'instant il ya la défense hitler
française depuis les forces de l'otan et
comme il n'y a pas de défense autonome
il n'y a pas de politique européenne
indépendante
alors bien sûr il ya des réunions il ya
des sommets dans lesquels on prend des
décisions comment des intentions qui se
traduisent dans des communiqués à
l'heure on constate on déclare que la
situation pologne est très grave
et puis simon a primé streetg on déclare
qu'elle est extrêmement grave
on déclare que la situation liban est
préoccupante
on propose pour le moyen-orient des
solutions qui n'ont aucune chance
d'aboutir puisque aucun des intéressés
n'en veut mais deux positions dures et
exigeantes sur un problème aigu jamais
parce que ça n'est pas possible
ce qu'il n'y a pas d'unité s'il n'y a
pas de défense indépendant alors qui est
devenue l'europe pour nous eh bien c'est
devenu une alliance franco-allemande je
devrais plutôt dire germano française
dans laquelle nous emboîtons le pas
constamment monsieur helmut schmidt
alors je ne conteste pas du tout la
nécessité de rapports étroits avec
l'allemagne mais il est bien évident que
nous n'avons pas les mêmes nécessités
politiques l'allemagne puisqu'elle est
partagée est perpétuellement tirés entre
deux nécessités son souci d'appartenir
au monde libre et la nécessité
d'entretenir de bonnes relations avec
l'union soviétique pour avoir de bonnes
relations avec l'allemagne de l'est
nous ne sommes pas du tout dans cette
situation nous n'avons pas du tout les
mêmes nécessités de ce qu'on a appelé
lost politique et nous n'avons pas du
tout à subir les mêmes pesanteur or nous
les subissons et cela nous entraîne à
des positions qui ne sont pas des
positions de force dans les relations
est-ouest
car voilà quel est le chapitre essentiel
ce qu'on appelle les relations est-ouest
ce sont les relations capitale pour le
monde occidental entre le monde libre et
l'union soviétique et les pays qui
dépendent de l'union soviétique
alors là il y à une donnée de base qu'il
ne faut jamais oublier l'union
soviétique n'est pas un pays comme les
autres
depuis la révolution communiste
c'est un pays qui est qu'un objectif
avoué officielle est déclarée
la conquête du monde et la conquête du
monde pour une idéologie la conquête du
monde pour le communisme alors dans
cette conquête
il faut bien savoir
ni les hommes ni le temps ne compte ni
les morts ne compte ni les victimes ne
compte ni les dirigeants ne comptent ils
n'ont aucune espèce d'importance si les
états sont des monstres froids l'union
soviétique est un monstre froid parmi
les monstres froids
elle n'est pas dirigée par des hommes
les dirigée par un bureau politique et
penser que parce qu'on a des
conversations avec tel ou tel
on peut avoir une situation privilégiée
c'est une illusion est une illusion
coûteuse alors depuis des années depuis
la fin de la guerre froide c'est à dire
depuis cuba en 1962 les relations
est-ouest sont dominés par une idée
qu'on a appelé la politique de la d'être
qu'est ce que c'est que la politique de
la détente
un petit bijou de très ambigu et
d'ailleurs de très changeant au départ
le général de gaulle avait pensé que la
fin de la guerre froide permettra des
échanges économiques et politiques entre
l'est et l'ouest et à la faveur de ces
échanges permettent de réveiller les
nationalismes la vigueur des états qui
avaient été annexées par l'union
soviétique
après la deuxième guerre mondiale cette
conception de la détente
elle est morte à prague en 1968 il a été
clair à cette date que la fin de la
guerre froide n'entraînait pas pour les
soviétiques l'acceptation de ce que l'on
a appelé la détente idéologique et si
cela était nécessaire
nous en aurions une deuxième preuve
actuellement en pologne alors la détente
après prague a pris un aspect plus
technique du temps de nixon et pompidou
la détente a consisté en des échanges
économiques dans les intérêts
réciproques de l'est et de l'ouest et
dans un système de vigilance mais
surtout dans une situation d'équilibré
internationale ou l'ouest étaient plus
forts que l'est
et ça c'est capital
parce que là des temps c'est une bonne
politique quand on est le plus fort et
ça n'est pas une bonne politique quand
on est le plus faible
quand on est le plus faible ça s'appelle
la collaboration c'est tout à fait
différent et sa masse que giscard
d'estaing ne l'a pas compris et
lorsqu'il est arrivé aux affaires il a
cru que la détente économique les
échanges économiques et politiques
pourraient entraîner un rapprochement
entre les deux blocs
alors nous sommes allés health inc qui a
healthy qui nous avons accepté de céder
aux revendications ancien de l'union
soviétique et à partir de là tout a été
noué
nous avons donné aux soviétiques la
possibilité d'engranger et d'avancé et
ils l'ont fait ils se sont ré armés ils
ont envahi l'afghanistan et ils ont
avancé dans deux directions qu'ils ont
très clairement défini le golfe pour
nous priver du pétrole et l'afrique par
libyen et cuba interposé pour nous
priver des matières premières et qu'est
ce que nous avons fait eh bien monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing est allé à
varsovie
alors il nous dit maintenant je dis des
choses très importantes à varsovie
mais ça n'est pas le problème ce qui
s'est dit à varsovie mais ça n'a aucune
espèce d'importance ce qui est versé
dans les archives que nous pourrons lire
dans 30 ans n'a aucun intérêt
le fait politique ce n'est pas le
contenu de la conversation qui est le
fait d'aller à varsovie
c'est le fait qu'après une invasion
déclare inacceptable le chef d'état
d'atp champion de la liberté se rend
dans une démocratie populaire rendre
visite à l'agresseur sous la garde des
autorités militaires soviétiques
ça c'est un fait qu une double
signification d'une part nous nous
sommes désolidariser d'avec le monde
libre et d'autre part nous avons accepté
ce que nous avions déclaré inacceptable
alors corps et il peut le faire
et bien il aurait fallu faire exactement
l'inversé
il aurait fallu réunir autour de nous
nos alliés
même si ceux ci étaient parfois affaibli
désuni et hésitant il aurait était de
notre devoir de leur donner force
courage et unités pour que le monde
libre puisse parler d'une seule voix et
dire ce qui était permis et ce qui était
défendue et que ceux qui étaient
défendus seraient sanctionnés nous ne
l'avons pas fait et je le regrette mais
maintenant nous sommes à nouveau dans
une situation qu'il faudrait exploiter
si j'étais en charge de ce pays
je consulterai d'abord mes alliés
européens puis je rencontrerai monsieur
reggane car la france est actuellement
dans une situation de force par rapport
aux états unis mais elle ne le sera pas
éternelle les etats unis qui se sont
redressés ont besoin en europe d'un
allié sûr et indépendant nous sommes la
seule nation européenne à pouvoir être
s'est alliée depuis que le général de
gaulle nous a fait sortir de l'autre
tant et qui nous a dotés d'une force de
dissuasion nucléaire autonome
nous sommes un pays adultes nous sommes
un pays qui est sans doute plus faibles
économiquement ou militairement que les
états unis mais qui lui est égal
politiquement nous n'avons rien à
prouver
au regard de notre indépendance nous
sommes capables de discuter d'égal à
égal avec qui que ce soit y compris avec
monsieur reagan et si actuellement il a
besoin de nous nous sommes dans la
situation où nous devons discuter les
termes d'une nouvelle alliance dont la
base serait une entente sur ce qui est
essentiel c'est à dire la défense du
monde libre la défense des valeurs dans
lesquelles nous croyons qu'ils nous sont
supérieures
nous sommes chargés de défendre et si
nous établissions un accord sur ces
bases alors nous devrions nous pourrions
négocier avec notre partenaire amérique
des accords dans lesquels nos intérêts
économiques militaires stratégiques et
politiques serait respectée voilà la
politique qu'il faudrait mener
vous savez non seulement à la politique
est une question de relation de force
mais lorsqu'on est dans une situation de
force même relatif comme celle que je
viens d'évoquer
il faut l'exploiter c'est cela la vie
politique comme la vie tout court alors
voilà je crois qu'elle devrait être
les choix qui devrait être posée à notre
pays car c'est d'eux que dépendent tous
les autres c'est très gentil de proposer
des plans pour le redressement de
l'économie que mon front tous nous si
nous dépendons des l'union soviétique
pour le gaz
et si les agissements de monsieur
kadhafi qui galopent en liberté nous
prive de matières premières africaines
comment ferons nous
comment ferons nous pour nous
approvisionner ea qui vendront nous ces
choses là ne se règle pas à l'intérieur
de l'hexagone
elle se règle dans le monde soyons
ouverts sur le monde c'est la vocation
de la france ce pays n'est grand que
s'il est tourné vers l'extérieur s'il
voit son avenir si le construit c'est
son intérêt lui c'est l'intérêt des eaux
et c'est à mon avis ce qui devrait être
le fond du débat qui nous occupe
actuellement
car c'est le destin de notre pays pour
les années qui viennent
c'est cela qui est important est ce cela
dont on ne vous parle pas ou dont on
vous parle avec des mots de suffisance
les français sont des citoyens et non
pas des sujets ils ont le droit de
choisir leur destin ils doivent choisir
en connaissance de cause
ils choisiront celui qu'ils voudront
mais on doit leur donner le choix
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
j'estime
il est de mon devoir de me employé
autant que je pourrai
[Musique]